je fais une bonne émission
et pourquoi moi je vais je vais même
encore aller plus loin je trouve que à
l'âge adulte à l'âge adulte quand on
regarde des dessins animés franchement
ça fait hyper peur c'est hyper anxogène
moi je ne peux plus regarder Dumbo je
peux pas regarder les 101 dalmatiens
[Rires]
les gens
moi c'est génial
à mais sans déconner
la vérité la dernière fois je suis
d'accord avec elle il y a des trucs qui
peuvent faire peur
on part des mots qui sont offensants
pour certaines minorités c'est normal je
suis d'accord je suis d'accord et il y a
des trucs voilà qui me plaisent pas
voilà les dents
on voit qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes sont
de plus en plus agressifs peut-être
qu'il faudrait même dans la même
commencer par les dessins animés parce
que c'est hyper anxiogène je pense que
quand les parents regardent les dessins
animés avec les enfants nous on le voit
pas la même manière
[Rires]
c'est impossible c'est impossible là il
y a un replay c'est obligatoire albatum
alors que l'auteur vient de
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci Cyril à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bonsoir vous êtes le monsieur qui qui
bonsoir qui enfonce les auteurs de manga
bonjour
ça ton problème c'est ça ton problème en
fait c'est une homme
le capitaine Corsair
du fin fond de l'univers
Cyril on peut en parler qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans ta tête au moment où ta
langue a fourchée comment est-ce qu'on
passe de Albator à Albator
tu pensais à quoi parce que non je
voulais faire parce que j'ai pensé et en
fait c'est parce que voilà j'en avais
parlé un ami et je lui avais dit et
voilà et donc voilà je pensais à le
batteur voilà parce que j'aime bien mais
non parce que voilà j'aime bien j'aime
bien tout ce qui est voilà j'aime bien
tout ce qui est dessin animé moi aussi
je regarde Dumbo
le weekend